thank you alejandro yes i'm here with uh
gary kasparov
the big boss behind the grand chess tour
yesterday i received an email
uh with a very big news about the grand
chester bring that uh to us
gary if you don't know what i'm talking
about i'm talking about two very
surprised players that are going to
take part in the grandchestering croatia
well i don't know it's surprising we
already talked about it so
it's the i uh i uh so now
no other option but you to to play blitz
uh
uh in zagreb you know i'm a croatian
national and uh
um you know uh while you know i couldn't
of course play the classical chess in
2019
but this year i had no excuse so and uh
and i um let's uh even challenge to
play rapid and uh i will do whatever i
can you know just playing two games with
blitz not
i don't want you to have very high
expectations but you know
i will have fun and hopefully others as
well and we challenge
uh justice is joining so he has to
survive the current team yes in croatia
because he's flying from india
so we will have two two former world
champions um and um i
think it just will add you know spice to
the tournament and definitely the
organizers are quite pleased
you've played with most of these players
who are you looking forward to uh
most to rekindle the romance over the
chessboard with oh absolutely another
look you know i'm i'm
not a professional player who's just
sitting now just preparing for this one
or that one
every game was a fun so as this is like
if if i can
do well in a couple of games that would
be great so i
i mean i know my limitations these days
i know that's you know it's the it's uh
i it's that it's very difficult to
switch you know just from doing
so many other things you know into uh
into just
playing mode i'll have about 10 days in
croatia just to get my
you know myself in order and to make a
little preparation so just to to feel
the the game of chess again the chess
pieces but
i i remember from my experiences in
saint louis that
you know even if there's a good position
it just it's even if things going well
still you know the risk that somehow
it's kind of a blackout
because yeah you cannot control your
mind completely so
okay now i only play chess i could you
know you know um
brush off everything else somehow just
it's it's it's uh
it comes back and forth it's a it's a
it's a sub-course a cycle you cannot
control but
again people you know will be happy
seeing me playing bishop playing and i
think that's that's again that's what
crunches tour is about you know to make
uh chess fans happy and uh and casper of
chess you know is
is also benefiting from from the
interest that graduate generates
speaking of kasparov uh chess i was
scrolling through the platform
and one of the things that really drew
my attention were
the documentaries are we going to see a
kasparov chess
documentary on you during croatia maybe
well you know it's the the
the personal stories are making a very
important part of of our communication
with
with the customer base and i i'm doing
when i have time just
a podcast an audio recording about my
early years so and i hope i will just
probably manage
to add more more episodes that's to go
to early 80s
and um and we also had few videos there
and and of course you know if there is a
good
video footage we'll definitely add it
because
telling about chess you know you you
must add this personal touch
and we know that's that's what people
value most and
um that's that's the whole idea behind
the sport of chess
and every time we have a good
opportunity and good
material good footage so it will be it
will be there to combine
playing and teaching
learning and entertainment i think it's
absolutely invaluable to get to know
these players on a personal
uh level speaking of these players let's
see what's happening i
i see we just have a result in the game
between mamedyarov and aronian aronian
has
long overdue what happened there i don't
know why this is i
i couldn't believe my eyes you know when
erodian played bishop d7 at
move move now move 19. and he played
very quickly and this is
yeah it was just you know opening
preparation and and he equalized
again just he spent few minutes just to
to reach his position
and here you know uh giving a check and
then developing the bishop or playing b5
so
it seems to me that it's it's it's a
drop and white maybe tiny tiny just
uh better but it's again it's
this should be shouldn't be any any
problem for black to to equalize
comfortably so bishop d7 is already
blundering the pawn but to to make
things worse enough
couldn't be three so he he probably
could have
you know hauled up the bishop c6 and
giving up f7 pawn yeah so he decided to
give a
b7 pawn but you know ironically he lost
first b7 and then his sound
they were after bishop c6 you know he
could he could um
uh he could you know just uh maybe
survive for
yeah maybe maybe he had a chance of so
maybe again we don't know so this is the
uh
whether whether he could or not it's
still a pawn it's still a point
it's but we i don't know what's what's
happened but he just you know uh
uh um here you know he made a terrible
blunder and he played it so fast
it's very very fast because i think he
just you know he made very quick
calculations but
i don't know this is that's the stage
it's uh
you know how come did he play rookie so
this is he played rookie
oh yeah fair very fast yeah is it a
matter of at this point you're playing
so
fast and you just think the position has
to give you the resources uh
to to to equalize and then you saw that
your opponent just look upon you play
rookie
instantaneously just to show that you
have control
i'm on the impression that is somehow
it's it's it's connected to
to to uh to online practice because this
is kind of a move you make there
because i don't know just he'll tell you
more about this but maybe after rookie
80 take the bishop of seven maybe he
thought you know
maybe bishop b3 because somehow it looks
oh this is this is
it's made and this is the pawn is
untouchable but okay of the bishops we
can resign
absolutely uh like only he can tell the
truth but it's a
it's um it's a typical you know online
move so let's just this this blitz move
so
and um now in classical chess in in real
tournaments so it's uh the punishment is
it's swift is exactly is very sweet it's
very swift
uh this one seems to be just going
through a draw i don't think anything is
going to happen in this one
actually no this is this you go back for
a moment
i'm curious yes this is the yeah yeah
yeah that's yes it seems yeah it's it's
a draw yes
okay what about this one what's
happening this one christian wants to be
winning
i think as he may like actually it was
not clear i think he made a mistake so
there's some more
yeah um i didn't like but here i think
his king 7 was the only chance
and i still think it's pretty pretty
lousy but at least you know you could
you have a king protected and then
there's through b5 and
this is mission this is uh yeah either
rook h8 or maybe bishop a6
and i mean some chances i think it's
still lost but
just at least you could have some
chances i think the movie they were
criticizing was
uh very much bishop b5 yeah we should be
five didn't look good yes that's
that's the but okay it's it's a very
suspicious opening and
and uh now now now white is white is
winning and it's just
uh i think it's yeah we'll see how
krishuk is going to
to to finish him off but he's he has
only four minutes on the clock so this
might be a problem nevertheless the
position seems to be
now speaking about grishook you know you
should say he has four minutes not only
four minutes
hopefully he ends up having one minute
four four
four fifteen moves he has now four and a
half minutes 44 and have been this way
it's like 45 yes exactly so that's why
okay as i would say yeah moving on to
this one
the game between wesleyan i think
presley had a better chance but still
you know he's pressing
his presence he's pressing this this and
just he's collecting you know this is
the
uh you know tiny tiny advantages here
and there so i
maybe for an untrained eye it would look
like black actually has the advantage
because you can no but this
is this the bishop is controlling the
pawn so the you can you cannot advance
uh and again maybe potentially white can
start attacking this maybe
some of you played g3 and then just you
know then i don't then
i don't know what to find out knight of
four so that's why you that's why i
thought about g3
yeah but that's why starting this was
just but it's just the i don't know this
is the
actually i see computer was king g1 was
the id bishop history that's the but
that's the
that's that's a computer move right
that's a computer movie go back and then
just to activate the bishop and because
it's just attacking but
this knight is hanging that's
interesting so this is this if night
goes
away then then there are more threats
actually yes that's interesting but
close and gear is a good defender so
very close gary has 25 minutes wesley
only four minutes so
this is still going to uh yeah but
actually play a role in five moves yes
but he has to make the move now so
that's that's and that's it's you know
could
could probably decide so how the game is
exactly
critical moment and i think well
basically it does around it seems like
we're going to get quite a few
uh interesting results yeah but but we
didn't talk about the the most
most exciting game of the round oh the
one that we have yes
the mvl versus amazing
an amazing game so i just it's it seems
again that you know
carolina outperformed it did uh uh in
praise preparation
uh yep has the same the same happened
okay it was uh the same opening fiasco
um you know um happened in in extreme
candidates so and here he played white
and i think this they played fairly
quickly and uh
and it's amazing he just you know
release this d this is like
because the yeah this is this the whole
idea this is
this to take on f2 and then play e4 so
this is this
and white you know white has an extra
piece but look at all these pieces are
here
black gold pieces are there and i think
the position probably should be roughly
equal but unreal it's very complex i
think they were mentioning after knight
takes
f4 was a mistake i think rook g5 was the
move
well that's not that's not easy to just
yeah yeah just to find but
i think i'm real new about this move new
he knew about it because
you go into the same position after
queen h6 h4 and you get this position
yeah and i guess he just forgot the uh
the move order he started with f4 but
after
g5 you're not forced to do that you can
just play f5
and big mess that's that's that's lost
but it's amazing that corona didn't find
a fairly simple win so i think it's just
you know just having
so many lines you know well prepared so
just when we reach this this moment
so look queen f6 is not you know it's
not
not an easy move to see it's not in this
move
is knight d5 but i understand but still
you know but this is this uh
it's it's very i mean you have to start
calculating he spent he spent
seven minutes and this is you know this
it's
that's what just makes a difference
between great player and and a very
strong player so
you have to understand this is the
climax of the game this is where you can
spend all the time because you find the
right move
you you win it's like a nexus you cannot
miss this turn
and um and he played fairly quickly in
knight this three i would have
spent more time here because he could
afford spending time so this is it's
50 minutes maybe 15 20 minutes because
you just you know it's you have to
calculate and
queen of six is the most natural one so
i'm sure there are other interesting
moves but
did you show that the winning line is we
did yes yes yeah this is again that's
that's that's that's and did go on to
see it
uh he did not see it so basically what
he missed was i think knight d5
um rook takes c4 check check and knight
f6 here this is the moment yes but you
know the moment your queen
appears sort of to you though that's
already that's the and he played 93
and did he miss bishop before he did
bishop before yes and yes and all of a
sudden you know there's white you know
white
pieces developed and bishop appears only
five and it's uh
it's often happens you know that he
missed his chance and it's it's a draw
gary thank you very much for your
insights so it was a great round so
great round we had you know just
it's a great show and some blood so i i
wonder you know this maybe they had you
know this is this
that's during the race day they get a
special vaccine you know to to
to increase the fighting spirit
absolutely they did and we cannot wait
to see you
in the action game okay come on that's
this is i'm i'm now hitting the road
again so
just you know uh flying to france so uh
yeah
i see our viewers you know at
granchester in paris absolutely
guys